okay instant well sums of basic hole now
a little salt don't let don't weather
here topic get hold strongly folk doing
say my hen cake over here he'll grab and
on a move before he gets jumpsuit they
hold through his love he takes holy in
kind of stronghold Heather difficult for
me to move some so direction to the home
comes forward into my center doesn't
move across here we across the areas of
transport back is a direction to the
whole the pressures into I second now
when I move it I can't just move any old
how to become physically get around you
got hearing something quite painful
funny to find the movement here shakes
my arm find the correct move neither so
here these are the right station right
shape right new so sheet money here in
the same shape and if it's moving here
so we've artists to learning from static
hold if I learn this shape on I need to
move while doing your move
I'm doing on the movies harder to no
work will it right through flocking I'm
almost through anything
those are moving with it which is you
are vision moving these are our teachers
trying to learn the correct body shape
from now if we double man which
approaches take this is different way of
doing the same thing you just coming
from different direction so probably
some people I need you to learn from
static of people by
moving once alright the role to vote
they be at the same place in fact here
now we're going to do out yelling
to get off line babies move not moving
but there is a slow coming into it and
pressure coming doors I need to move off
line here and thank you balance now
Stevens that it is more difficult
because I can't you need Mumma can you
is slow yeah I can use that forward
pressures are very also restricts my
movement so it places restraint on why I
can do to the good thing you know learn
how to deal with it so it's reducing the
attack to my simple hole in forward so
it simplified it's typical Aizen
technique allowed me to isolate my moves
to deal with this particular attack
we're going through different act here I
think of that there's different sort of
noodling a neutral in similar rooms
maybe what needs and I need to deal with
it or two hands or stripe so the mousse
is if I'd down they're not strict
technique so yeah I want to be here in
each square against beyond giving
recognition get that chin area there
this teaches of fundamentals of the
techniques principles of the technique
so when you see opportunity to use a
technique you can save you it's not the
basic techniques about learning moves
and are well so expense or throw really
okay
[Music]